كشف تحقيق اجرته شبكه سي ان ان الاخباريه
الامريكيه عن تدنيس جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ما لا يقل عن 16 مقبره في غزه
في هجومه البري على القطاع وذكر التحقيق
ان عمليه التدنيس التي قام بها جيش
الاحتلال في المقابر الفلسطينيه ادت
لتدمير شواهد القبور وقلب التربه وتجريف
في بعض الاحوان وكشف
الو الجسام
وكذلك القبور في خنون الجنوبيه قطاع غزه
واخرج منها جثثا بذيع ان ذلك جزء من البحث
عن رفاه رهائن محتجزين في غزه وقالت سي ان
ان انها راجعت صور الاقمار الاصطناعيه
والمقاطع المصوره التي تظهر تدمير المقابر
كما شاهدت ذلك مباشره اثناء السفر مع
الجيش الاسرائيلي في احدى القوافل وخلص
التحقيق الى الادله مجتمعه الى ان الادله
مجتمعه تكشف
عن ممارسه وصفها بالمنظمه مع تحرك القوات
البريه الاسرائيليه عبر قطاع
غزه